one town seemingly wiped away in one
evening mayfield kentucky where a candle
factory with 110 people inside was
leveled a trapped worker took to
facebook live to plead for help we are
trapped please y'all get us some help
we're at the candle factory in mayfield
please
please
she got out but the governor believes
the vast majority of workers did not
seeing an entire downtown
wiped out
knowing the loss of life that occurred
here and muhlenberg county and
everywhere else this is this is the
hardest tornado event we've ever been
through and it's not just because of the
property damage but we lost a lot of
good people
and we got to do our best as it gets
dark and through the next days to make
sure we don't lose anymore the storms
with as many as 30 tornadoes could be
seen from space
tornadoes that came down and stayed down
causing damage for more than 300
kilometers this path length i believe
when it's all said and done we're
waiting for the numbers to come in will
be a near 400 kilometer path length and
very likely that this tornado will be
rated violent which means ef4 ef5 i'm
expecting winds
peak wind speeds to be well over 200
miles per hour with this particular
tornado
and it wasn't just kentucky an amazon
warehouse in illinois a nursing home in
arkansas destruction in missouri and
tennessee
states that expect tornadoes but not
usually in december president joe biden
spoke to the nation calling for unity
promising the full support of the
federal government and reminding people
of what has been lost imagine
if your home's in the past what do you
go home to
what do you worry about i mean
everything's gone from that
from that uh
that baptismal photograph
to the wedding picture to
the picture of your
oldest daughter in a ballet i mean
it's it's it's profound
it's just profound a federal emergency
has been declared in kentucky with other
states likely to follow and the national
guard has been called in to help clear
roads and search door to door looking
for survivors knowing the death toll is
likely to rise
patti culhane al jazeera washington